hi this is nina
a while ago i made a smoothies video
and then um there's a comment from liz
torres
she said avocado and smoothies i wonder
how that tastes i generally don't like
avocados but i wonder how avocado tastes
with fruit i love avocado i put avocado
in my salad
and my sandwiches and my smoothies um
sometimes i could even eat avocado by
itself i don't add anything to it it's
really good
i like avocado because it's really good
for you
lowers your heart rate it lowers your
back cholesterol
and tastes great too so today i'm gonna
make avocado with banana so i'm gonna
cut the
avocado in half
oh it's a bad one let me get another one
what if we don't have a good avocado we
should do it from the beginning
oh my god this is so bad sorry guys the
the avocado they're not that great
uh once i might just get some we're
gonna buy some good avocados tonight
and then maybe we'll reshoot the video
again sorry
these ones are pretty good the the skin
turn color
and when i press it in it's a little
smushy but not too hard
when you look the green ones they're
hard i can't even push it in
this is how you open a bag okay you
don't try to pick at it with your nails
it takes too long you open it up here
okay see where you know the top is like
this
okay so um we're back with the avocado
actually let me tell you how many um of
each ingredient that we need
uh one avocado and one banana i froze it
banana so i don't need to use ice
one teaspoon of lemon juice i'm gonna
squeeze it out later
and then uh one cup of almond milk
and two tablespoons of raw honey
i love raw honey i can just eat the raw
honey with a spoon
avocado same thing cut it in half
i hope this one is good oh it's good
it's green
okay take the pit out then use the spoon
to scoop out the um
the avocado meat so one frozen banana
one cup of unsweetened almond milk one
cup
okay and then two tablespoons
of raw honey so the raw honey
it looks like this uh you can see a
whole
a hole in the middle uh because we
ate it okay so this is one tablespoon
and then i need another tablespoon
oh it's hard okay
so that's two tablespoon i could i could
smell the raw honey
i love it it's yummy okay so
so for the lemon um if you notice the
last one
i i always press down the lemon so when
i squeeze it out it's easier to squeeze
this squeeze the juice out
you can also replace the lemon with um
with lime but i like lemon more than
mine so
cut it in half then gonna squeeze the
lemon into this bowl
see it's very easy to squeeze the water
out
use one teaspoon
so that's one teaspoon you can add more
if you want i'm gonna use
i'm just gonna use one teaspoon so all
the ingredients
are in here i'm gonna blend it up
okay it's done let's see
this is the smoothies avocados with
banana smoothies
okay let's um pour into glass
and then have evan taste it
come over here cheers seriously
i can't even drink like this oh my god
oh god thanks for watching this video
please like the video and leave a
comment and let me know what
i should make next please subscribe to
the channel and
believe bye okay say bye
okay bye hello does it work
i'm gonna use unsalted unsalted
unsweetened almond milk uh raw onion raw
honey
she asked um she asks
uh she has epic
yeah this is not great let's get another
one
oh no i prepare it oh
i broke this oh my god
okay so how can i open this i can't
believe that
one cup of unsweet
unsweetened almond milk hurry up
i need to finish with this so um
oh i forgot what i want to say i forgot
now okay stop it
you're interrupted you're interfering
with my thoughts
ready oh it's really good
ready oh my god
okay you're gonna break this thing
just
okay come are you okay
sign up for the newsletter for more
believe
you